Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my new Batman DC Fandome trailer they just
released a bunch of trailer for trailers will
explain what's going on that also been a lot
of test screenings for the Batman movie is
a really cool details of gotten out so will
break that down to if you're brand-new to
the channel, be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos of course will be doing videos
for all this stuff this is just a taste of
what's coming the Batman movie is just the
biggest thing that they're going to be hyping
up at this upcoming DC Fandome event in October,
which seems familiar.
It was kind of the Pièce de résistance of
the original DC Fandome back in 2020.
Like I said they have been screening cuts
of the Batman movie recently for test audiences
and it's been all good news people are calling
it more of a horror movie.
If you been looking for darker Batman movie,
they say Paul Dino's regular is genuinely
terrifying in their supposed to be this big
shocking twist at the end of the movie, which
may sound familiar.
If you look at the twist at the end of all
Batman movies if you been a long time fan
of Batman movies, the comics, the animated
series.
The other TV shows post all your theories
about what you think that shocking twist is
going to be keep in mind though test audiences
that are reporting these things are groups
of people who are not supposed to be Batman
experts are just mostly like regular people
off the street so shocking twist of them might
not seem so shocking.
If you been reading Batman your whole life.
But the general vibe of the movie is that
Robert pattinson's Batman is only in his second
year year to Batman in the as uncovered all
of the criminality of Gotham city yet.
He's been going after the surface level criminals.
It just based on the last big Batman trailer
the Riddler despite being a classic Batman
villain is trying to expose all this corruption
in Gotham city.
Like he kills the mayor that's what this body
is supposed to be.
But at the crime scene.
He lays all this evidence all over the place
exposing the mayors lies.
He calls out Batman during the trailer his
voice over demanding that if he truly seeks justice
he'll stop turning a blind eye to what the Riddler thinks
are the real criminals in Gotham is been a
long time trope of Batman stories movies,
TV shows that the politicians the judges the court system
Even the police are just as bad as the regular
Batman villains like the Joker the Riddler two face
I'd say Catwoman but she's not a Batman villain
in the way you normally think of Batman villains
she is a true neutral character alignment
sometime she works with the villain sometime
she works with Batman will pricy both of those
during the movie.
Just like in Batman returns with that version
of Catwoman Zoe Kravitz is playing the Selena
Kyle version of Catwoman during the Matt Reeves
Batman universe in apparently test audiences
love all the Catwoman stuff.
So it sounds like Zoe Kravitz is going to
kill it is the new Selena Kyle, the villains
are often some of the most if not the most
exciting part of the movie for me throne shall
be incredible somewhat I wanted to do was.
I wanted to see a Batman that was not an origin
tale that was sort of in his early days.
That meant that a lot of the characters who
are the rogues gallery characters are in their
origins in a way, and so we have a Selena
Kyle who's not yet Catwoman Selena to The
South incredibly past.
She really wants team fight Alioth those who
don't have someone else to fight for them.
I think that is where Batman she married what's
most interesting of us in the Kyle is that
she represents the Savior for the ill treated
the forgotten the people that have not had
anybody looking after them.
She's also very complicated you don't quite
know exactly where her loyalty or her legions live
They also reported is a lot of good Alfred
scenes with Andy serkis's version of the character.
He seems like a much more intense version
of Alfred even though Jeremy Irons Alfred
was pretty intense the also confirmed that
they're going to be showing off the new flash
movie trailer and you may remember there was
a big featurette for the movie that leaked
a while ago Warner Bros. took it down superquick
which is why didn't make a video about it.
But during that trailer.
They show you Ezra Miller flash inside Michael
Keaton's back cave with his Batman.
It looks like a much larger version of his
back cave from the Tim Burton Batman movies.
Mostly because it is easier for them to do
more more spectacular version with modern
special-effects the also depicted scenes of
the big team up fight with Michael Keaton's
Batman in a version of his classic Batman
suit from the Tim Burton movies.
It seems very familiar to the original suits,
he's flying in a version of his bat jet wall
Supergirl in the flasher on a building seeming
like there in the middle of a fight scene
and there were a couple other scenes of Ezra
Miller flash inside Michael Keaton's Batmobile
with Batman driving around it it all the previews
I got a lot of questions about this they kept
blurring someone's body out.
Like, there's 1/3 person standing with them,
and sometimes in the background that they
kept blurring out like an extra person in
the background here that they don't want you
to see because of spoilers and based on all
the recent rumors and scenes from the movie,
they got out separately.
I think that blurred person is supposed to
be the secret main villain of the movie and right now
the rumor is that instead of reverse flash
because this is a flashpoint inspired story
instead of him there actually going with the
dark flash like evil Barry from another universe
as the villain of the film and during all
the shots with blurring man here in the background
it's actually very writing around with evil
Barry in Batman also in the larger fight scene
with her all teaming up together.
Like it's them fighting evil Barry in that's
why he's blurred out, because they don't you
to see that he looks just like the flash if
you watched any of the flash season 3 episodes
They kind of already did a version of this
also as part of their version of the flashpoint
story their version of events evil.
Barry was pretending to be's avatar completely
different flash villain and he was a time
remnant version of Barry from the future who
was supposed to die but didn't.
I just got done doing a bunch of videos about
Loki.
Which kind of got into this whole idea, but
they called those types of characters on Loki
variants like a nexus event happens when a
character does something.
They were originally supposed to do and then
it creates a branch timeline that turns into
an alternate reality in that person becomes
a holy alternate universe version of themselves
was kind of what happened with evil Barry
on the TV show during the flash movie.
It seems like evil Barry is just an alternate
universe version of Barry to begin with.
And I don't know if he's meant to be the original
flash of Michael Keaton Batman's earth, but
will probably get more clues about that when
they release the official trailer Ben Affleck's
Batman is also feature prominently in the
movie.
I just did a big preview video for all the
scenes of him the posted a while ago.
So I link that video blown the description
he's writing a version of his bat pod this
inspired by some Zack Snyder concept art from
the Justice league Snyder cut Zack Snyder
had a version of a jet powered motorcycle
the Ben Affleck's Batman would've used in the movie
But it didn't make it in.
I think just like too many other ideas that
he had to got too expensive.
But the difference was that it would've been
like a small personal jet craft that he flew
around instead of driving around on wheels.
So obviously this one is a little bit different.
But as Andy Mushietti's version of a Zack
Snyder concept during the flash movie.
All they've said so far is the Ben Affleck's
Batman is supposed to give the flashes new
multiverse flash suit upgrade beyond that
you can theory craft about them doing a new
version of the letter scene from the end of
the flashpoint story but because they don't
have his father Thomas way in the movie at
least as far as we know.
I'm sure Jeffrey Dean Morgan is just waiting
for that flashpoint Batman call early theory
they might wind of doing a version of the
letter scene.
But just have the letter come from older Michael
Keaton Batman speaking to a younger Ben Affleck
Batman giving him Sage life advice if it wasn't
clear.
They're not using the flashpoint storyline
to retcon out Ben Affleck's Batman.
He'll still continue to be the main Batman
of this prime earth of the Justice league
universe next big thing.
They also announced the be showing off some
peacemaker previews that's the suicide squad
spinoff TV show with john cena's peacemaker
character.
I boarded than a big suicide squad movie post
credit scene video.
So a link that blown the description.
That's basically a teaser for the peacemaker series
They released a new poster this morning to its
him in his car which if you not a big muscle
car junkie this is an old Mercury Comet and
I love the license plate reads as if it says
peacemaker, which feels very apropos for his
character the bumper sticker is just a reminder
about the DC Fandome panel they're doing in
October.
He has the Washington plates.
Because that's where he lives there was a
preview of him earlier standing outside his
mobile home where he actually lives when they
were filming the episodes like this is his
house that he lives in and as you can see
from his house from the stripes that are painted
on the car the paint job is costumes color
scheme everything he has is painted with the
colors or painted to look like the American
flag because he has such a hard on for justice
and lady liberty in peace he loves peace so
much he doesn't care how many people he has
to kill to get it.
Thus the peace sign he's making with his hand
out the window here in also this is kind of funny
James Gunn was laughing about this hidden
maybe not so hidden detail that not many people
were calling out when they first released
this poster earlier this morning zoom and
enhance on this rear car window is a bald
eagle sitting in the backseat of his car.
He has a pet bald Eagle which if you didn't
know is the national bird of the United States,
so of course he would have a bald eagle is
a pet.
I believe they were endangered species for
a while, so you might be breaking the law
little to actually have one as a pet.
I think it might be illegal to have one as
a pet.
I'm sure Amanda Waller is just looking the
other way as part of his deal working for
her on a continuing basis the peacemaker series
will be eight episodes on HBO Max starting in January
They haven't given the official release date
yet though, but will be sometime in January
and it'll basically be him going on more missions
for Amanda Waller, James Gunn says that the
series gets into way more sci-fi stuff than
you're expecting and the peacemaker episodes
will crossover with other future DC movies.
They haven't announced yet.
Like you will set up future DC movies.
But they haven't said which ones I will be
doing videos for all the episodes.
Just like I do for the marvel Disney plus
series and as you can see this is basically
DC doing their version of the marvel Disney
plus series they're doing today Green Lantern
HBO series they're even doing a Batman HBO
series spinoff from Robert pattinson's Batman
movies Matt Reeves is doing it himself.
The only other really big thing that they're
releasing it DC Fandome is supposed to be
the black out on teaser trailer, like actual
footage from the movie, they released a preview
teaser last year but was more of a concept
are trailer for height with voiceover narration
my next big video will be my full marvel what
if episode four video.
That's all about dark Doctor Strange we just
got done watching the Spider-Man No Way Home
trailer and Doctor Strange seemed kind of
weird during that.
So very timely the releasing a dark Doctor
Strange episode of what if that video will
post Wednesday morning.
Just like normal make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss it
everyone click here for my full Spider-Man
No Way Home trailer video and Easter eggs
and click here for that brand-new Black Panther
2 wakanda forever first look video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next video!